que alexis poulain éditorialistes alexis
poulain bonsoir merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france alors le chômage
partiel a beau avoir été largement
déployées durant le confinement
les conséquences économiques se font
donc ressentir dans les foyers français
qui sont ces français qui aujourd'hui
ont basculé dans la précarité bien ce
sont ceux qui attendaient une
pérennisation de leur emploi en cdi ce
qui était en cdd qui pensait dans la
restauration notamment pouvoir avoir
plus d'emplois
ceux qui attendaient que l'économie
reprenne et ce n'est pas le cas et donc
vivre aujourd'hui avec un smic
et bien c'est difficile c'est même de
l'avis de la plupart des le français
sous le seuil de pauvreté vous dire
combien c'est difficile de finir le mois
et encore pire quand vous êtes au rsa et
que vous êtes mère célibataire ou père
célibataire et que vous devez élever vos
enfants
les gens souffrent aujourd'hui la
réalité c'est que beaucoup de français
plus d'un sur deux ont peur de tomber
dans la précarité c'est l alerte
important il y a deux ans des gilet
jaune qui voyait bien là où on voulait
emmener la plupart de la population
française vers davantage de
paupérisation parce que c'est politique
mise en place depuis 2010 est et même un
peu avant et bien n'ont fait que creuser
les inégalités et qu'il faudrait l'avis
de beaucoup et bien enlever les
solidarités et ce n'est pas le cas et
c'est dangereux parce que à partir du
moment où vous perdez votre emploi à et
bien c'est le risque de perdre votre
logement et de vous retrouver à la rue
sans rien c'est à dire c'est une
précarisation grandissante et cette peur
là elle est présente davantage depuis
2007 ce sentiment de précarisation n'a
fait qu'augmenter dans la population
française et rien n'a été fait pour bien
y remédier on a appris cet avenant de
relance alors bruno le maire est très
fière allure sur une relance par exemple
vous vous avez plusieurs milliards qui
sont mis bien sûr pour essayer de sauver
les entreprises à maximum et tant mieux
parce que les entreprises créent
l'emploi mais sur la pauvreté sur la
lutte contre la pauvreté la précarité
seulement 200 millions d'euros ce n'est
pas à la hauteur on est loin du compte
aujourd'hui on voit bien que la pauvreté
la lutte contre la pauvreté n'existe pas
dans la tête des responsables politiques
et c'est aux associations est bien de
faire ce qu'elles peuvent pour sauver
des gens de la famine pour sauver des
gens de la rue et parfois ce n'est pas
suffisant on l'a appris cet après midi
le dispositif de chômage partiel à 100%
est maintenue jusqu'à la fin de l'année
pour tous les secteurs protégés et non
pour le seul secteur de l'hôtellerie
restauration
ce type de mesure est ce que ça va être
suffisant selon vous non ce type de
mesure est nécessaire évidemment
aujourd'hui compte tenu du choix du
gouvernement de fermer les commerces les
bars l'instant on est au train donc il
va falloir aider ces secteurs qui sont
sinistrées et pour longtemps l'aérien le
transport donc le chômage partiel c'est
une bonne chose
jusqu'à la fin de l'année on peut se
demander pourquoi et que va-t-il se
passer après est ce que la croissance va
revenir à ce que la reprise est préparée
annoncé est ce que les emplois vont
pouvoir reprendre regarder autour de
nous c'est plan social après plan social
que ce soit dans l'industrie dans le
transport les petits commerces qui met
la clé sous la porte
les fleuristes qui ferment on a les
chiffres maintenant qu'il commence à
arriver et donc ce chômage partiel
jusqu'à la fin de l'année c'est un peu
pour essayer d'amortir la chute qui va
être terrible mais les gens ne sont pas
dupes ils craignent évidemment pour
l'avenir parce qu'ils n'ont pas de
perspective
et je ne vois pas la perspective est là
ce n'est pas que le fait du gouvernement
français dans la reprise de l'économie
mondiale après ce blocage complet par le
virus
donc il faudrait au delà du chômage
partiel penser à ceux qui vont qui
risque de tomber dans l'extrême
précarité et qui ne peuvent pas dépendre
simplement des associations ou bien de
la générosité des gens parce que le
secours populaire se féliciter que 5000
personnes soient bénévoles soit des
nouveaux volontaires qui rejoignent
leurs rangs mais ce n'est pas ça qui va
faire qu'on va éviter que de nombreuses
familles se retrouvent à la rue il va
falloir un plan en un plan pour l'hiver
un plan pour saisir des logements vides
pour faire en sorte que on évite la rue
à de nombreuses familles et puis pour
que en attendant que l'économie reprenne
eh bien ces gens là ne meurent pas de
faim et on peut le faire parce qu'on a
les moyens on a la chance d dans une
économie développée en france et en
europe
or malheureusement nos politiques sont
obsédés par la croissance parle sauver
les entreprises
il faut aussi penser aux humains à ceux
qui souffrent au quotidien qu'ils sont
obligés de se priver de repas qui saute
beaucoup de repasser dans ce rapport du
secours populaire qui et qui
malheureusement n'ont pas d'autre choix
que ces associations pour éviter la mort
par famine tout simplement
derrière cette précarité également
alexis poulain les enfants le secours
populaire craint notamment que les
familles soient en incapacité par
exemple de payer la cantine comme en
face à cela faut-il réagir selon vous
oui alors il y à aussi au sein de ce
sondage les gens qui répondent et qui
ont peur parce qu'ils ont vu le
décrochage scolaire ils n'ont vécu c'est
à dire que quand l'école a fermé on a
pensé qu'il y aura une continuité
pédagogique un de manière dématérialisée
avec les ordinateurs avec internet
or pour des familles au rsa pour
beaucoup de familles il n'y a tout
simplement pas d'équipement informatique
il n'y a pas de connexion à internet il
ya donc des enfants qui se sont sortis
du système scolaire et beaucoup de
familles qui ont peur en fait d'un
déclassement parce que leurs enfants
n'ont pas pu rattraper le temps perdu du
confinement et là encore je ne sais pas
ce qu'a prévu jean michel bancaire pour
ces enfants là quelques elle va être
quelles vont être les mesures qui vont
permettre justement de dd à rattraper et
surtout assure une continuité
pédagogique pour ceux qui n'ont pas de
matériel
or même s'il ya eu des promesses en
disant que si jamais il fallait qu'on
finit il y aurait des ordinateurs on
attend les preuves
on attend de voir où sont ses
ordinateurs est ce qu'on va pouvoir
équiper des familles qui en auraient
besoin notamment pour leurs enfants pour
éviter
et bien qu'on creuse encore davantage
des inégalités et qu'on se retrouve bien
dans un apartheid social ou les très
riches vivent très bien malgré la crise
et où les très pauvres rentrer dans un
monde qui est celui et bien de la peur
du lendemain et du risque de famine
alors pour conclure vous évoquiez tout à
l'heure les gilets jaunes on se souvient
de cet élan de cohésion au début
du mouvement notamment sur les ronds
points est ce que ce type d'élan pour
être à nouveau venir secouer l'exécutif
dans les semaines les mois à venir
la mobilisation elle existe comme je le
disais 5000 volontaires de plus les gens
sont solidaires
beaucoup de français se rend compte
qu'ils doivent faire quelque chose pour
aider leur prochain
le problème c'est au niveau des palais
de la république où on vit bien on mange
bien on est sous les dorures et où
finalement on parle davantage aux
financiers internationaux aux donneurs
d'ordres aux grands patrons et qu'on ne
voit pas la réalité c'est ce qu'on
appelle la solitude du pouvoir alors
emmanuel macron a pourtant fait des
maraudes il a vu ce qu'était la pauvreté
dans la rue mais au delà de la mise en
scène pour prendre des photographies
qu'est ce qu'il a appris qu est ce qu'il
va se passer derrière qu'elle va être
quelles vont être les moyens de donner
ces associations et au delà de ça qui
est que va faire l'état pour éviter
l'extrême pauvreté parce qu'encore une
fois la pauvreté est un choix politique
et que fait le gouvernement aujourd'hui
eh bien il veut continuer sur la réforme
des retraites continue et sur la réforme
de l'assurance chômage qui vont me faire
qu'accélérer la précarisation de
nombreux de france
c'est donc c'est un autre sens ou bien
c'est un choix et si c'est ce choix là
qui est fait et bien c'est le choix de
la pauvreté et le gouvernement devra
l'assumer
merci beaucoup alexis poulain j'appelle
que vous êtes éditorialistes